IN TEXAS FOR AT LEAST 14 DAYS.
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT CASEY, STAY
DRY, IT LOOKS A LITTLE WET DOWN
THERE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE
WHITE HOUSE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE BY HOLDING YOUR DAILY
PRESS BRIEFINGS AND THEY ARE
WATCHED BY MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS.
SO ARE THEY HELPFUL IN PROVIDING
PERTINENT INFORMATION OR DO THEY
RISK SENDING MIXED MESSAGES?
LET’S BRING IN FOX NEWS MEDIA
ANALYST HOWARD KURTZ, A HOST OF
MEDIA BUZZ.
I GET A GOOD COP, BAD COP,
TOTALLY GET THAT.
I KNOW RIGHT NOW EVERYONE IS
HANGING ON THE THE PRESIDENTS
EVERYWHERE TO COME AND HOW HE
SAYS EIGHT SYLLABLE, WHAT HE
LOOKS LIKE WHEN HE SAYS EIGHT,
THE TONE WITH WHICH HE SAYS IT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> OF THE PRESIDENT WAS BRAGGING
ABOUT THE RATINGS FOR THESE
DAILY BRIEFINGS BUT THEY ARE
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY AT A TIME
DURING SUCH NATIONALLY NATIONAL
THE PROBLEM IS THE PHRASE HE YOU
USED, THE MIXED MESSAGES
SOMETIMES BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT’S REASSURING APPROACH
AND THE WARNING OF HIS TOP
MEDICAL EXPERTS WHICH LEADS TO
CONFUSION AND GENERATE STORIES
ABOUT DIVISION IN THE
ADMINISTRATION.
BUT THAT CHANGED YESTERDAY WHEN
THE PRESIDENT SEEMED SOBERED BY
THE WARNINGS HE GOT FROM ANTHONY
FAUCI AND DR. DEBORAH BIRX.
SO IF ALL THE RESTRICTIONS WERE
RELAXED AS MANY AS 2 MILLION
PEOPLE COULD DIE AND THAT
PRESIDENT REPEATED THAT FIGURE
16 TIMES AT YESTERDAY’S PRESSER.
>> Dana: HE WAS REALLY TRYING
TO DRIVE THAT HOME FOR PEOPLE.
I ALSO WONDER ABOUT THE OFFHAND
TO SPITBALL INCOME OF THE
BRAINSTORMING, LIKE MAYBE WE
WILL DO THIS OR MAYBE WE WILL DO
THAT, LIKE THE IDEA OF THE SHUT
DOWN A NEW YORK, CONNECTICUT AND
NEW JERSEY.
IT TURNED OUT NOT TO BE THE CASE
BUT PEOPLE ARE LISTENING TO
EVERY SINGLE WORD THAT HE SAID.
>> YOU KNOW, AND I THOUGHT MAYBE
I HAVE TO GET OUT, AND I CAN’T
GO VISIT FAMILY ELSEWHERE, AND
THAT SORT OF THING.
FOLKS FELT BLINDSIDED BECAUSE
THEY HAD JUST TALKED THAT DAY
AND THEN IN THE END THE
PRESIDENT DIDN’T DO IT SO THAT
UNDERSCORES YOUR POINT ABOUT HOW
WORRIED ABOUT WE ARE IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT.